that's why a dragon hoards gold it's
like what's up with that
well it'll eat you and it will but it
has gold well so what do you do about
that
because it's it's paradoxical demands
well what you want to do is face the
dragon and get the damn gold that's what
you want to do well you have to be a
paradoxical being even to do that so you
know in a hobbit for example when
what's-his-name Frodo right isn't it's
not Bilbo it's Bilbo in the hobbit you
know he's kind of this little
underdeveloped overprotected Shire
dweller and he called on a great
adventure to go and find the dragon and
he has to become a thief in order to
manage it well that's pretty weird
you know it's like well it's because as
a good citizen he's just not enough to
conquer a dragon he has to also become a
bad citizen in some sense he has to
incorporate the part of himself that's
monstrous let's say and develop that and
hone it and that's to say that well if
you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless you're like a
rabbit rabbit isn't virtuous it's just
just can't do anything except get eaten
it's not virtuous if you're a monster
and you don't act monstrously then
you're virtuous but you also have to be
a monster while you see this all the
time Harry Potter's like that too it's
like he's flawed he's hurt he's got evil
in him he can talk to snakes man he
breaks rules all the time all the time
he's not at obedient at all but you know
he has a good reason for breaking the
rules and if you couldn't break the
rules him and his little cleek of rule
breaking you know troublemakers if they
didn't break the rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal so
it's very peculiar but it's very very
very very very very common mythological
notion you know the hero has to be there
has to be a monster
but a controlled monster Batman is like
that you know I mean it's everywhere
it's the Tor story you always hear
meaning we have to be more precise well
that's that's a good that's a good
question you know because one question
is you know you're kind of implicitly
moral insofar as you're socialized but
that's sort of procedural it's just
built into you this is different this is
also becoming conscious of it and
expanding out your personality into
dimensions that it wouldn't normally
occupy so it happens to people all the
time so for example lots of my clients
my clinical clients are too agreeable
and they're generally women because
women are more agreeable than men but
not always because I've had agreeable
men as clients as well and what happens
is they're resentful and and they don't
know how to stand up for themselves it's
because they're very compassionate by
nature and so if you're entering into a
negotiation with them they'll let you
win well that's not so good because you
know you need to win too especially if
you're in an organization of adults
where there's there's a struggle right
when you have kids you can let them win
especially infants like you have to let
them win and that's partly why
compassion is so necessary but as a as a
basis for negotiation between adults
it's like sorry it's insufficient you
have to you have to be a bit of a
monster so that you can say no and so a
lot of what you do in psychotherapy is
treat people they anxiety and depression
that's a huge chunk of it help them
straighten out the way they think that's
a huge chunk of it but another chunk of
it is well let's toughen you up you know
let's put you in a position where you
can bargain let's teach you how you
assert yourself and stand up for
yourself and that's assertiveness
training and it's a huge chunk of
psychotherapy and you need to you need
to learn it it's like because part of
how you regulate your interactions with
other people is to negotiate and you
cannot negotiate unless you can say no
you can't do it and it causes conflict
to say no and if you don't like conflict
which is basically the definition of
being agreeable
then you can't tolerate the conflict and
so then you can't negotiate on your own
behalf and so then you keep losing and
you're bullied and you know it's not
good then you get resentful and it's
really not good so you have to develop
your inner monster a little bit and and
then that makes you a better person not
a worse person it's weird it's weird but
but that's just how it is